más grande que nosotros,
entonces estoy en el lugar correcto,
porque este último año,
tuve un año interesante con una película que hice llamada "Crazy Rich Asians"
(Aplausos y vítores)
Gracias, gracias.
Y si estamos hablando hoy específicamente de conexión,
entonces sé que mi historia sólo es posible
debido a una colección de conexiones que sucedieron a lo largo de mi vida,
así que espero que al contar mi historia,
ayude a alguien más a encontrar su camino un poco más rápido que yo.
Mi historia comienza cuando, por primera vez, abrí el libro sagrado...
El libro sagrado de los artilugios, claro, "Imagen más nítida".
(Risas)
Sí, los que saben.
Era una revista mágica de sueños,
y tenía cosas ahí que sabías que no podían existir,
pero estaban justo ahí.
Podías pedirlas; venían por correo.
Y algunas cosas que quizá nunca debieron haber existido,
como "Gregory", un maniquí portátil
que disuade el crimen con su fuerte y masculina apariencia.
Es un verdadero...
(Risas)
Esto es algo real, por cierto.
Pero mis ojos estaban puestos en el Sima Video Ed/it 2.
Esta cosa era genial a la edad de 10 años.
Podías conectar todos tus reproductores VHS
y armar algo,
así que convencí a mis padres para que me lo compraran.
Pero antes de entrar en eso,
déjenme darles un breve resumen sobre mis padres.
Vinieron a EE.UU. cuando eran jóvenes,
son de Taiwán y China
y se establecieron en Los Altos, California,
el Silicon Valley antes de Silicon Valley,
y montaron un restaurante llamado Chef Chu's.
50 años después, todavía trabajan en el restaurante,
siguen ahí,
y crecí allí, así que fue genial.
Hablando de conexión, este lugar era un centro de conexión.
La gente iba ahí a celebrar cumpleaños, aniversarios, negocios,
comer, beber…
conexión.
Y me tocó crecer en ese ambiente.
Y mis padres siempre decían que EE.UU. era el mejor lugar del mundo.
Puedes...
Si amas algo, puedes trabajar duro y lograr lo que quieras.
Entonces, criaron a cinco niños estadounidenses.
Soy el más joven,
el que tiene los ojos cerrados ahí,
y nos nombraron a mi hermana y a mí, Jennifer y Jonathan,
en honor a Jennifer y Jonathan Hart del programa "Hart to Hart".
(Risas)
tanto amaban a EE.UU., aparentemente.
Y pensaban que éramos Los Kennedy,
mi mamá específicamente,
así que nos vestía igual todo el tiempo
y nos puso en clases de etiqueta y clases de baile de salón,
se aseguró de darnos un buen plan dental.
(Risas)
Esta es una foto real mía. No es falsa.
Gracias a Dios.
Yo estaba a cargo de la cámara de video cuando nos íbamos de vacaciones,
así que yo coleccionaba estos videos y no tuve nada que ver con esa.
Por lo tanto, el Sima Video Ed/it 2,
los convencí de que me lo compraran,
y me pasé toda la noche tratando de sacar todos los videos
de la habitación de mis hermanos, enredado en cables,
y ahora tenía algo que mostrarles.
Así que los llevé a la sala una noche,
probablemente en 1991, aproximadamente,
y los senté en la sala.
Mi corazón latía con fuerza, mi respiración era profunda,
algo así como ahora,
y presioné el botón de "play"
y algo extraordinario sucedió en realidad.
Ellos lloraron
y lloraron,
no porque fuera el video casero más asombroso de la historia,
aunque era bastante bueno...
(Risas)
sino porque veían a nuestra familia como una familia normal que encajaba
y pertenecía a la pantalla frente a ellos,
al igual que las películas y los programas por los que nos pusieron los nombres.
Recuerdo que, siendo el menor de los cinco niños,
me sentí escuchado por primera vez.
Había un lugar donde todas estas cosas en mi cabeza
podían entrar en el gran lugar eléctrico de algún lugar, existir y escapar,
y supe desde ese momento
que quería hacer esto el resto de mi vida,
ya sea que me pagaran o no.
Ttenía esta pasión y necesitaba herramientas,
y mi papá se fue a trabajar.
Continuó alardeando de mis habilidades de edición de videos caseros
a los clientes de Chef Chu's,
y afortunadamente esto es Silicon Valley,
así que ellos trabajan en cosas como hardware y software,
todos son ingenieros,
y me ofrecieron darme cosas para la edición de vídeo digital.
Esto es como a mediados de los 90, principios de los 90,
donde estas cosas no existían para chicos como yo.
Así que conseguí este software y hardware beta de lugares como HP y Sun
y Russell Brown en Adobe,
y no tenía un manual,
así que lo resolví y me enamoré aún más.
Comencé a ir a la Escuela de Artes Cinematográficas de USC
y mi mamá y papá siempre me llamaban y me recordaban
que tenía que hacer películas sobre mi herencia china.
Que China iba a ser un gran mercado para las películas algún día.
Yo así como: "Sí, claro, chicos".
(Risas)
Siempre escuchen a sus padres.
Yo quería ser Zemeckis, Lucas y Spielberg.
De lo último que quería hablar era de mi propia identidad cultural,
de mi etnia.
Y francamente, no tenía con quien hablar,
no había nadie en la escuela con quien abrirme realmente,
e incluso si lo hacía, ¿qué diría?
Así que lo ignoré y seguí adelante con mi vida.
Resumiendo, 15 años después,
lo logré en Hollywood.
Fui descubierto por Spielberg,
trabajé con La Roca, Bruce Willis y Justin Bieber.
Incluso vine al escenario de TED para presentar mi compañía de baile LXD,
y fue genial.
Y luego, hace un par de años,
me sentí un poco perdido, creativamente.
El motor estaba bajando la velocidad,
y recibí una señal...
Escuché voces del cielo...
o más bien eran como pájaros.
OK, está bien, fue Twitter.
Y Twitter...
(Risas)
Fue Constance Wu en Twitter,
fue Daniel Dae Kim,
fue Jenny Yang, quien está aquí hoy,
fue Alan Yang.
Todas estas personas que escribían sus frustraciones
con la representación en Hollywood.
Y realmente me impactó.
Pensé en estas cosas pero nunca me involucré realmente,
estaba muy centrado en...
y me sentía afortunado de trabajar,
y entonces me di cuenta:
sí, ¿qué es lo que está mal en Hollywood?
¿Por qué no hacen esto?
Y me miré en el espejo y me di cuenta de que yo era Hollywood.
Realmente,
estaba presumiendo antes de llegar aquí,
así de Hollywood soy.
(Risas)
¿Siguen despiertos? Ah bien.
(Aplausos)
Durante todos estos años sentí que me habían dado tanto,
y ¿qué estaba devolviendo al negocio cinematográfico que amaba?
Tenía suerte de estar aquí,
pero en ese momento, me di cuenta de que no sólo era afortunado,
sino que tenía el derecho de estar.
Me gané el derecho de estar aquí.
Todas las noches de insomnio y las fiestas que me perdí los viernes,
cada amigo y novia que perdí porque estaba editando,
me gané el derecho de estar aquí no sólo para tener una voz sino para decir algo,
y decir algo importante;
y tenía, en realidad, el poder,
el superpoder para cambiar las cosas si realmente, realmente quería hacerlo.
Cuando tratas de contar historias sobre ti mismo
y sobre gente que se parece a ti y a tu familia,
puede ser aterrador,
y todos los sentimientos de estar solo regresaron.
Pero internet fue lo que me dijo
que enviara la señal, que iba a haber todo un ejército esperándome
para apoyarme y amarme por ello.
Así que encontré la increíble novela de Kevin Kwan "Crazy Rich Asians"
y nos pusimos a trabajar.
Juntos hicimos esta película.
Elenco asiático...
el primer elenco asiático en 25 años con una historia actual...
(Aplausos y vítores)
Pero cuando empezamos no había garantía en absoluto.
No había ninguna compensación para este tipo de películas.
Cuando hacíamos encuestas y cosas así,
el público no iba a aparecer.
Incluso en las proyecciones de prueba
en las que dábamos entradas gratis a la gente para ver la película,
teníamos una proporción de 1 a 25,
es decir, de 25 personas, sólo una decía que sí,
lo que es super bajo para este tipo de cosas.
Los asiáticos que conocían el libro no confiaban en Hollywood,
los que no conocían el libro pensaban que el título era ofensivo
y otros que no eran asiáticos simplemente no pensaban que era para ellos.
Así que estábamos bastante bajoneados.
Por suerte, Warner Brothers no nos dio la espalda.
Pero entonces la energía volvió a la carga,
y un ejército de escritores, reporteros y blogueros asiático-estadounidenses,
que por años se había abierto camino en sus respectivas publicaciones,
se puso a trabajar, sin que yo lo supiera.
Y empezaron a publicar cosas.
Además, algunos fundadores de tecnología comenzaron a publicar cosas en las redes,
a escribir cosas sobre nosotros en artículos en "LA Times",
en "The Hollywood Reporter" y "Entertainment Weekly".
Fue como este levantamiento de base para hacernos noticia.
Qué cosa tan asombrosa para ver.
Y el gran apoyo se convirtió en una conversación en línea
entre todos estos asiático-estadounidenses
donde pudimos debatir y discutir
qué historias queríamos contar,
qué historias debían ser contadas,
qué tipo de...
¿podemos burlarnos de nosotros mismos?
¿Y el casting? ¿Qué se nos permite hacer?
Y no estábamos de acuerdo, y todavía no lo estamos,
pero ese no era el punto.
El punto era que la conversación estaba sucediendo.
Y este flujo de conversación se convirtió en una infraestructura.
Se necesitaron estos diferentes grupos que estaban tratando de lograr lo mismo
y nos puso a todos juntos en este tejido conectivo.
Y de nuevo, no era perfecto,
pero era el inicio de cómo determinábamos representarnos en la gran pantalla.
Se volvió más físico cuando fui al cine.
Nunca olvidaré haber ido, fin de semana de estreno,
fui al cine, y no eran solo asiáticos,
sino todo tipo de personas,
y entré y me senté,
y la gente se reía, la gente lloraba,
y cuando entré en el vestíbulo,
la gente se quedó allí.
Es como si no quisieran irse.
Se abrazaban,
chocaban las manos, se tomaban selfis,
debatían y se reían al respecto.
Todas estas cosas diferentes.
Tuve una relación muy íntima con esta película,
pero cuando estábamos haciéndola,
no entendía lo que estábamos haciendo hasta que sucedió:
que era lo mismo que mis padres sintieron cuando vieron nuestros videos familiares
en esa sala ese día.
Vernos en la pantalla tiene un poder,
y solo puedo describirlo como orgullo.
Siempre he entendido esta palabra intelectualmente.
probablemente he hablado de esta palabra,
pero para sentir realmente orgullo,
y aquellos de Uds. que lo han sentido lo saben,
es como si quisieran tocar a todos y agarrar y correr alrededor.
Es como un...
No puedo explicarlo.
Es solo un sentimiento muy físico,
todo debido a un largo patrón de conexión.
El cine fue un regalo que se me dio,
y a través de los años he aprendido muchas cosas.
Puedes planear, escribir guiones, hacer tus guiones gráficos,
pero en un momento dado,
tu película te hablará
y es tu trabajo escuchar.
Es este organismo vivo que se presenta de alguna manera,
así que es mejor que lo agarres antes de que se te escape,
y esa es la parte más emocionante de hacer películas.
Cuando veo la vida, no es tan diferente en realidad.
He sido guiado a través de este tipo de migajas de conexiones
a través de la gente, de las circunstancias,
de la suerte.
Y cambió cuando me di cuenta de que una vez que empiezas a escuchar
los ritmos silenciosos y los ruidos desordenados alrededor,
te das cuenta de que hay, ya escrita para ti, una hermosa sinfonía.
Una línea directa a tu destino:
tu superpoder.
Ahora bien, el cine fue un regalo
impulsado por mis padres y apoyado por mi comunidad,
llegué a ser quien quería ser cuando lo necesitaba.
Mi mamá publicó algo en Facebook el otro día,
lo que suele ser algo muy malo para decir en voz alta,
asusta, ella no debería tener Facebook, pero...
(Risas)
Ella publicó algo, un meme,
ya saben, una de esas cosas divertidas,
y decía, "No puedes cambiar a alguien que no quiere cambiar,
pero nunca subestimes el poder de plantar una semilla".
Y dándole los últimos toques a esta charla,
me di cuenta de que todas las conexiones poderosas en mi vida
fueron a través de la generosidad, la bondad, el amor y la esperanza.
Así que al pensar en mis películas "Crazy Rich Asians" y "In the Heights"
en las que trabajo actualmente...
(Aplausos y vítores)
Sí, es buena.
Lo que quiero hacer es mostrar alegría y esperanza en ellas,
porque me niego a creer que nuestros mejores días quedaron atrás,
sino más bien, que están a la vuelta de la esquina.
Porque, vean, el amor,
el amor es el superpoder que me dieron.
El amor es el superpoder que recibí.
El amor es lo único que puede detener una bala que va a toda velocidad
antes de que sea disparada.
El amor es lo único que puede saltar sobre un edificio
y hacer que toda una comunidad mire hacia el cielo,
junte sus manos,
y tenga el valor de enfrentarse a algo muchísimo más grande que ellos mismos.
Así que tengo un desafío para mí y para los aquí presentes.
Mientras trabajan en lo suyo,
en su compañía,
y estén creando, y haciendo posible lo imposible,
no nos olvidemos de ser amables unos con otros,
porque creo que es la forma más poderosa de conexión
que podemos dar a este planeta.
De hecho, nuestro futuro depende de ello.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y vítores)
(Aplausos)